Wow! (running) 100 miles.
It looks like impossible, but not.
because of course it'll be hard,
but if you know why you are here,
if it's a dream,
I'm sure it's possible to do.
- Good.
Well, thank you for doing this.
It's so nice to meet you.
I can't wait to learn about your life.
I'm excited to talk to you.
And here we are in a running store
in Boulder, Colorado,
doing this podcast,
Old School On the Road.
And yeah, how are you doing today?
How are you feeling?
How are you getting your head straight
for the big Hardrock 100?
- Yes.
All of that.
(man chuckling)
I'm so, so happy to be there
to make it to the US again.
And I really enjoy this part of the season
and the year,
and since yes, two years.
I'm so happy to build my season until June
where I moved to Colorado,
and yeah, this year will
be special for sure too.
And already today because I'm
so happy to discuss with you.
I follow a bit your life,
and your different podcast,
and it's always interesting to have,
yeah, this kind of a
different approach of running,
and it's amazing to be
here to discuss with you.
- I appreciate that.
And you know, and kind of
reflecting on your life
and your career,
obviously you're one of
the greatest of all time
in trail running.
Four UTMB wins.
You won Hardrock last year,
set the record,
you're going into Hardrock again,
coming up in a very short
period of time here.
And my sense is that you're
very celebrated in Europe,
but that in the United
States, or in North America,
perhaps less so.
So I have a very specific
agenda for this podcast,
which is to help raise
awareness of your amazing talent
and career.
- Career, it's to be.
(man laughing)
- No, no.
Well it's an interesting moment
because I think that the
interest in trail running
and adventure racing is
on the rise very much so.
People are getting into it
and it's just growing at an
explosive rate right now.
And so I think that
North America is very primed
to learn more about your life
and how you've been able to
do the things that you do.
- Yeah, I'm happy to discuss about that,
but yeah, it's a bit party specific
because there's always,
yes, a comparison between
Europe and North America,
and everybody think in US and Europe,
everybody think it's totally different.
Trail running in US
is totally different than
trail running in Europe,
or in France.
And for me, not at all.
We are just happy to be in the mountain
and you have some very nice
and specific mountain here,
and in France too, in Europe too.
So for me it's just about being fascinated
to spend some long day in the mountain
and to recenter about yourself,
to try to, yeah,
to to be the better part
of you in the mountain,
and for some long day.
So yeah, for me it's not
being American runner,
or being European runner.
It's just being a mountain runner.
And that's why I'm so happy to
discuss with American runner
and to share my experience with them
because it's always interesting
and funny to see a bit
the media and how the people that can.
- Right.
- [Francois] Can discuss about that.
- That that seems like maybe
that's an American thing.
Like here in America we're thinking,
oh, we have a certain way of training,
but what are those guys over there doing?
In the Alps,
they're living in small villages
and they're just going out
way up into high elevation
every single day.
And perhaps,
because we don't have access
to those types of mountains,
that there's something to your lifestyle
or your kind of relationship with training
that is very different
than the way that the
Americans approach it.
And I've heard you say like,
you kind of disabuse
people of this notion.
You're like, no, it's not
actually that different.
But your friend Jim Walmsley
seems to be under that impression,
which is why he moved to France.
Feeling like that is
the missing ingredient
in his ability to kind of win UTMB.
He had to go and immerse
himself in that culture
and that lifestyle.
- We'll see,
but no, I think,
yeah, I think it could be
interesting to discuss with him,
but I think it's not
just about the immersion
in the French Alp
and French mountain made the difference.
It's maybe more is the
approach of the event,
more his approach of his training.
And I'm sure he can do the
same training in the US
and I have the same approach
if it takes time for that.
But I think in Flagstaff, it's very warm.
It's a bit more flat than in France,
but I'm sure that in Silverton
he can train even better
than in France for a race like UTMB.
But it, for me, it's
very, very interesting.
It's very nice to have a mountain
just like 200 meters from the house.
So we can share some very
good training at the moment
and I really appreciate him.
But as a those American runner,
it's always nice to, yes, to show culture,
to share some very good moment.
And yeah, I try to discover a bit more
the US culture,
because I like it,
and they like European culture
because I think it's something normal
that we are always more interesting
about what is different from
what we are are used to.
And for me it's very interesting
to discuss with American runner.
I was there I think
the first time in 2012,
but since 10 years now,
I'm always, always so
happy to came back in US
because I always learned
some different thing.
And I'm always impressed
about how big this country
and everything,
(man chuckling)
and try them.
In Europe and France,
some of the longest rides,
it's 100 miles,
and I was, like four years ago,
the beginning of the Pacific Quest ride,
It's 4,500 kids.
- Right.
- Just unbelievable.
So for me, it's amazing to be there.
- Yeah, I think,
correct me if I'm wrong,
the sense is that in the United States,
people who are trying to
train at a certain level
kind of complicate things
or get really into data and spreadsheets
and get very much up in their head
about how to approach these races.
Whereas a European sensibility
is more like we live in
these small villages,
we keep our,
our lives are very kind of
less complex in that regard,
and we keep things like
kind of very basic,
and you know, I do feel
like there's some shared DNA
with somebody like Killian
who will tell you
it's just about your
relationship with nature,
and it's about being outdoors,
and the humility,
and the experience of pushing your body
and just being alone with
the majesty of the mountains,
which is a different relationship
I think to performance
than the kind of American mindset.
- Yeah.
Yeah, you're right I think.
But it's, yeah.
Yes, another are open, I like that.
Not American, I like that too.
But I think it's more
about a neutral approach,
because I think when
it's more short distance,
it could be totally different.
But a neutral distance,
the approach I think must be different.
And I cannot speak for Killian,
but I think it's a bit same as me.
It's not that we, okay, we
want to be a top runner,
a new, try mountain
and so we have to do that now.
We did that,
and because of that
maybe we became some good, ultra runner,
but it's totally different.
But I want to became a good trail runner,
so I have to do that.
Just say, anyway, I do that,
so maybe I can became a
good trail runner or not.
But anyway,
we want to spend some
long days in the mountain.
We want to be there.
We want to train like that.
We want to have this kind of life,
and just, I think the performance
is just a consequence of our life.
And I can think that's the
approach of some American runner
is maybe a bit different.
Oh, I would like to win
new UMTB maybe one day
or something that,
so I have to train like that.
I have to do that.
And it's not, I think, the same way.
The beginning must be okay,
I'd like,
I would like to be in the mountain.
I would like to experience myself.
I would like to push my limits
to discover that kind of trail,
that kind of mountain.
And then the consequence would be that,
ah, because of that life,
because of that training,
you will be, sure, in front of the scene.
And for short distance,
I think it's not the same thing.
Okay, I want to be a
performer on short distance.
You go do training, whatever you want.
Okay, so I have to focus on my training.
I have to be professional.
I have to do that, that, that,
and then you have a result.
But on the trail,
I think it's too many things.
It's okay, it's the training,
it's the performance,
it's your body,
but first, it's a mentality.
It's a approach.
It's how we train.
And I know,
I know well I think Colton Walter,
you made you some post.
- Yeah.
- And I think she's one of those
who have this kind of approach.
She don't take care about the result,
the race, or everything.
What she like is to be out,
out in the mountain,
to spend some long day.
And then if she can win
a race, she's happy.
And finally is a result,
is just the consequence of what
she did all along the year.
She don't focus on one
race or another race.
If it's not working on one race,
okay, no work.
It's not good.
But no worry.
She have a another race or another plan,
and anyway, she's so
happy to train for that.
So it's not the same approach.
And I try to discuss a
lot with Jim about that
because if he's approach is,
okay, I would like to be
the first American runner
to win UTMB.
The pressure is really high.
I hope he will able to do that
because he's an amazing runner.
He's very, very good.
But the approach is, it's hard for me.
I think if I have that kind of approach,
it's impossible for me to win a race.
- Right, right, right.
So essentially what you're saying is
in the long run,
especially with these longer
distance mountain races,
achieving goals
only comes as a consequence
of the lifestyle that you live,
as opposed to being very
kind of driven towards
a specific result.
And I've heard you say,
I think it was with respect to,
maybe it was UTMB last year,
the question was like,
how do you shoulder the
pressure of going into UTMB?
You've won three times.
Can you do it again?
That must be overwhelming.
And you said something like,
"Well, if I win, great.
But if I don't, I'll take my kids
to go do something,
and I have a whole life outside of this."
And that was what kind of made me think
of the difference in sensibility
of kind of a European mindset
versus an American mindset.
Whereas the American would
be devastated if they lost
and they're clenching their fists,
and you know, trying to drive,
kind of will a certain result as,
so it's like the difference
between self will
versus being in the allowing, right?
Like if I'm living my lifestyle,
I'm allowing the result to unfold
that is meant to be as a
result of the decisions
that I've made about how I live my life.
- Yeah, it's true.
It's even more easy for me to say that
when you won it three times.
(man laughing)
- Right.
- Okay, you don't have pressure,
but you won it three times.
So it's easy to say that.
Okay, sure.
But for me, even the first time,
if I arrive at the start line
with this kind of pressure,
I'm sure I won't able to finish,
because I want to protect myself,
and at the start line
I don't want to have
this kind of pressure.
So I'm at the start line.
I say, okay, I have a very good training.
I have some two very good months
and I'm so happy to be there.
If I can win, if I can finish two,
on the podium, whatever,
it's so, so good.
So I will be so happy.
But if not,
it's okay.
It's just a sport.
It's just a pleasure.
- [Rich] Right.
- And my life will continue,
and I will have some possibility,
and some other chance.
But for me, it's taken like 20 years maybe
to arrive at the start
line with this position
and without any pressure,
and it's not easy every day.
Every day you have to work on yourself
and to say it again.
And that's why I don't want to go back
each year on the same race.
Like for me this year,
going back to a Hardrock 100 again,
just one year after
where you finish first,
when you break the record.
I was not expected that.
Last year I was thinking, okay,
it's just an experience for me.
Next year I will come back
and I will do it better,
but last year I finished,
I say, how can I do it better?
So this year, you came
back with a bit of pressure
because even for yourself,
you cannot say, okay,
I will be there just to try to finish.
Come on.
Last year you win,
you break the record,
you got no just here to finish.
(man laughing)
So for me this year,
it's a bit more pressure,
but that's why I try to
have a another approach
to say, okay, I'm here.
Last year, it was just incredible.
I was lucky.
So I'm I again,
so it's so good.
I'm so lucky too.
So it's another race,
it's another race.
There's some another runner.
So yes, I will,
I would like just to finish it
and to it just,
yeah, we are just 160
runners at the start line,
so I'm so lucky to be there.
Just a huge community of
ultra trail runner in the US.
It's just like a family.
Everybody are so happy to meet each other.
Like even tonight in Boulder,
I think it will be so nice to have a,
like a common event,
and for me I say, okay, please enjoy it
and don't push your pressure on yourself.
And with that way,
I'm sure the race would be good.
- Right.
It's such a healthy strategy,
and one that has longevity to it, right?
Because you're releasing yourself
from carrying that burden.
It's confidence in the preparation,
gratitude for just being able to be there
and be healthy and participate,
and also kind of a healthy respect
for all the variables
that you don't control;
the weather, and other people,
and all that kind of stuff, right?
Like, the longer the race,
the less control you actually have.
You just have the
preparation that you endured
just to get there.
And I was listening to your
conversation with Dylan Bowman.
You guys were talking
about Hardrock last year
and how you were,
you were kind of running near each other,
and realizing that you were like way ahead
the record that Killian had set
and thinking maybe perhaps
we've made a terrible error.
- Yeah, exactly.
(men laughing)
- And it all worked out.
But then thinking, well how
can I do better this year?
And saying, well, maybe I
don't have to worry about that.
I'm just here to experience the community,
and to do my best.
And I think the community piece
is also really interesting.
I know that last year was
the first running of Hardrock
in three years because of COVID,
and also weather conditions prior to that.
But you had come to
Silverton in 2019 nonetheless
to engage with the community,
train on the course,
and kind of,
now you've become kind
of part of that community
that you're returning to tomorrow.
- Yeah, exactly.
It was very nice in 2019
to be able to be there,
and we have some very good moments,
and we discover the race
without any pressure
with each other.
It was very, very interesting.
There's a lot of snow,
so it was very interesting
to play in the snow
because people like Jim,
they just learned how to run
on the snow four years ago.
So it was very interesting for me
to discuss about that with them.
And yes,
it would be very interesting
and it's not a good thing that
Dylan won't race this year
because here we are an incredible day.
So even for him, I think
he was not expecting
to run so fast at that basin.
Yes, during all the race we are thinking,
oh, maybe we're out too fast.
Anyway, we have a very
good day so we continue.
(man laughing)
- Do you think about
the other competitors?
I texted Dylan yesterday
and I said I'm gonna
be talking to Francois.
What would be interesting
for me to explore with him
that is something I can't
Google or find out online?
And he's like,
"I'm so fascinated by
Francois's relationship
with competition."
And we've already kind
of covered a little bit
of your sensibility with that,
but you seem so,
it's really not about like what
anyone else is doing, right?
Like, the longer the race is,
the less it is about some other performer.
It's just about your relationship
with you and the terrain.
- Yeah, yeah.
It's exactly that.
I don't take care about those runner
even before the race,
even normally during the race,
but I'm a bit too competitor.
So when I'm doing the race,
I really like and enjoy to
play with those other runner,
but it's not my main goal for sure.
- Do you think about,
oh, I know this runner uses this strategy
so I have to look out for that,
or do you not pay
attention to any of that?
- No, I know that,
and I play with that,
and I, yeah, you have time
to think during 24 hours,
so you can think,
okay, maybe this runner is going too fast
because I know him,
so I don't have to take care about that.
But you play with that.
But you have to,
your main focus must be on you,
otherwise I think it's too hard on you,
and that's why I really
like ultra trail running.
It's totally different
from the other distance.
I think even since 100K an hour,
and even more,
I think less than like
Western States time,
it's 40 minutes.
It's around like 14 hour I think.
- [Rich] Yeah.
- I think
more than 14 an hour.
It's another world.
- Right.
- So less than 14 hour,
I think now competitors are,
yes, well experienced.
They are training for that.
They are very conditioning for that,
so I think less than 14 hours,
it's more like athletics and race.
More than 14, 16 hour,
I think it's another world,
and more than 20 hour,
it's, again, something else.
So I think it's very important
to have a different approach
and that's why I think I'm still there
after like,
my first long distance was 2006, I think.
So it's 12 years ago
and normally you cannot
make it such long career
in high performance in sport.
- Right.
- But if I'm still there,
it's maybe because this is
the spot totally different
and where experience helps you a lot
and approach helps you a lot,
and yes, that's why I think
I still continue to progress
even if now I'm maybe too old for that.
- Yeah, no, no, no.
- But I really enjoy that,
and I think we experience,
it's something just interesting in Utah.
- Yeah, I mean there is a long history
in ultra running
where somebody will burst onto the scene
and they'll have unbelievable performances
for maybe two years, three years,
and then whether it's
over training, or burnout,
or whatever it is,
they're unable to ever kind
of match that level again.
You don't see very many people
who have longevity in their careers.
- Yeah, it's so sad for me,
and that's why I have
this kind of approach
and I try to push that kind
of approach for the media
because I'm so sad when I
see some runner just say,
okay, I will try to do six
or seven trail run in a year
or even four in a year.
Even in France, they have
some amazing runners.
They say, okay,
we like to do like UTMB,
and Diagonale des Fous,
and some other race,
and now it's,
I think it's too much.
Maybe it could be one year.
Like last year I tried
to running back to back
Hardrock and UTMB.
It's only six weeks,
but it was my only goal for the year
and I propose that once since three years,
and I run since 25 years.
So it's not just, okay,
you do it last year,
Next year you can do now.
No, it's something very special
and I won't do it again this year.
And I think for Killian,
he will try to do it this year
and even at the middle,
but it's Killian.
He runs since he was born.
- [Rich] Yeah.
- So it's not everybody
can do that,
because you mustn't do that I think.
Stop Martin, they did two race in a year
and it's two hour,
and for us, it's 24 hours,
so how can we do more than two race?
- Right.
- And I see
so many, many runner,
even American runner when I
start in 2012 they were there,
and now it's so hard for them.
I think about like Rob Krause,
or some people,
Jeff Rose or some people like that.
Even Anton, it's, yeah,
there was a race,
and maybe sometimes too much,
and then it was too hard to recover
and they were so good,
and I think maybe they get over train
or too much pressure
or something like that,
and then it's too hard
for the body to come back.
- [Rich] Right.
- So we have to be really,
we relax about that,
and we discuss a lot with Jim about that.
And this year that's why
he did a race in April,
and then he's okay.
Now I just focus on UTMB
and maybe it'll be my decision.
I think ah, it's a very good approach
and I like it
because you will be very fresh,
and I'm sure that next year
you will be there again.
And this is the most important for me.
Winning a race, it's important,
but be able to run again in five years
I think it's the most
important thing for us
and for our body.
- Yeah, sure.
I mean I think that the sport is maturing
in terms of how people
are understanding training
and performance.
Those runners that you mentioned,
and even the generation prior to that,
like very little was known
'cause people were pushing the boundaries
of the distances that anybody thought
humans could even run to begin with.
And so of course the mentality was like,
well if we can do that, let's train more,
let's train more.
And then suddenly all of these people
are kind of falling off the wayside.
But we saw Anton come back
after that long period of absence.
So I think there is that,
now it's like,
oh, well if you were one of those people
maybe you can rebuild in
a new and different way.
- Yeah, it was so nice to see him again,
and I chat with him yesterday
because I know that he
lived not so far from there
and he is a bit focused on bicycle.
- Yeah, he's out on Instagram
riding his bike everywhere.
- He will do 600 miles on Friday.
(men laughing)
Okay.
But yeah, it was so nice to see him again,
and yeah, and Anton,
Joe Grant, I'm sure I will see
him in Hardrock in two days.
It's so nice to continue
to discuss with them.
Every year I'm so happy
to meet Anna Frost,
and she was here even before me
in the trail running community,
and it's so nice to see
that that kind of people.
Okay, they're so happy
about their performance,
and about their career,
and which race that they was able to win,
but they are even more
happy to be still there
and still able to run.
And if you discuss with them,
they will, I'm sure
100% that they would say
it's the most important thing
is just be able to be
again in the mountain today
to be able to have some long day
and to share some nice one with
the people in the community.
It's even more important
than winning that race,
other race,
or pushing too much for that,
because in 20 years,
what will you remember?
Oh, I was able to do
that, but now I'm not.
I don't want to run anymore.
I don't want to be in the mountain.
- Right.
- I'm not
passionate about that.
Well, okay, I did that,
but I'm still there,
and I'm still so happy and
so passionate to do that.
And for me it's the most
important thing that,
okay.
- Remaining joyful
about the whole experience.
- I just want to be there
in five or 10 years with my kids
and to say, okay, I'm so happy
to share with you this loop
around Mont Blanc,
or, you know, kids, I
was there in Silverton
like 20 years ago,
and I now I'm still there with you
and I'm able to make a loop.
Ah, I think it's my biggest dream actually
even more than winning again the race,
is just too be there
in 10 years and to say,
okay, I was there,
and I can share it with you.
It's, wow,
this is for me the most important thing.
- That's all fine.
But come on, let's get honest here.
I don't wanna make you uncomfortable,
but like four UTMB wins.
I mean, there's gotta be a
killer under the surface there.
Like, what?
Why are you so much
better than everyone else?
(men laughing)
What is the secret weapon?
What are you doing that
others aren't doing?
Or how are you built physiologically
so that you are so
exceptional at this sport?
- I don't know.
(man laughing)
I'm so passionated
when you are at the start line,
if you build like, we speak earlier,
when you are the start line,
you just, you don't feel the pressure.
You just feel the power just to say,
wow, I'm here.
I wait that moment since
two years and I'm here.
So everybody say, oh, you
can do one or two nights
without sleeping and say, how can I sleep?
I wait that moment since two years.
I'm so excited.
I'm so happy to be there.
And then it's like you you have wings
so you can fly around the mountain,
and I'm so happy.
And then if the race goes like you want,
then you're okay.
It would be sunsets and sunrise.
There will be this pass.
It's so unbelievable.
And then, ah, you can fell your sensation,
you can fell your training,
you can fell what you
built since 10 years,
your strategy about food,
about that land,
about equipment,
about material, about family,
about everything.
There's a lot of thing.
And when everything match,
wow, then you feel it.
Okay, today, I'm perfect day,
and you don't feel it.
And even, I think last year in Hardrock,
I was even more fast at the
end than at the beginning
just because I was, wow.
Today it's just so incredible.
And I remember with Dakota Jones we play,
he pace me on the last part,
and we just playing and we
run all over all the time.
I say, okay, I'm even faster
than at the beginning.
It's just crazy,
and just no matter if
it's 10, 20, 25 hours,
you just happy,
and then you can feel that you,
yeah, you are just flying
and it's just a very good moment.
And yeah, this is what I try to,
these kind of sense of feelings,
I try to have on a race.
- Right.
Your emotional relationship
to the whole thing.
But as somebody who,
you have a background
in physiotherapy, right?
So from like a biological perspective
or a training perspective,
are you doing things in training
that you think others aren't,
or is there something about your,
the way that you're built?
Like, Killian has a crazy VO2 max,
or you know,
is there something that
makes you extra well suited
to this type of sport?
Or do you think it's just because
you've been doing it for a long time,
and like, I don't know.
I'm trying to wrap my head around.
- Yeah.
- I'm sure there are
other people that
participate in these races
who are very grateful to be there, right?
And have a love for the mountains.
So there is something
different going on with you,
is there not?
- No, it's right.
(man laughing)
- I'm trying to make you blush.
- If I have a scientific approach,
it's true that,
yes, I cannot complain
about my performance
and about my body,
but I think I have a very
different approach than Killian,
and I think Killian needs to be different
because he tried to be,
to perform on short
distance and long distance.
So, and I think it's not a secret
that Killian have some incredible capacity
and ability in terms of heart
and breath and everything.
- At a very high level of exertion.
- And me,
I practice as a team,
3000 steeple chase when I was young,
or cross country,
and I was not bad,
but I was not at the top level.
And I think, okay, I can run fast,
but not as,
yes, I was not very, very, very good,
not the top French performer,
but I think it was enough for
ultra trail, the distance.
And so I'm not,
I don't train just for
ultra trail distance
because during winter
I made some intensity
and something like that.
Not as Killian,
but more than 90% of people
which practice only ultra trail
in France, or even in
Europe, or US, I think.
So I think,
during winter I work a
lot on my physiology,
and on intensity, and something like that.
So I think it's to compare to Killian
because it's something different.
But if I compare some to the other
long distance, ultra distance runner,
I think on short distance,
I could be better than them,
but what I like is the
same approach as them.
It's spend some long day
in the mountains even more,
so I think I can have the
same endurance trainings
than them.
But if I want to push,
I can push a bit higher than them.
- Right.
- So it was interesting,
like last year in UTMB,
I think we have the same background
with the five or six as runner,
but because we play too
much with Jim Walmsley,
I was just so destroyed after 80K.
And in the distance, it
was hard for me to go fast,
but I know that if I want
to push in each ascent,
I can make like four or five
minutes faster than the other.
So it was so comfortable for me,
not comfortable, because painful,
but it was very interesting for me to say,
okay, even if I lose three
minutes in each descent,
it's not so bad
because I can easily put
them five or four minutes
in each ascent.
So I think for me,
it's very interesting
to have this background
just to know that okay,
in ultra distance, I maybe like the other,
but if I want to push,
I can push a bit more.
- You have that extra gear.
- [Francois] Yeah.
- In your back pocket you
have the confidence to know
it's fine I'm running with you right now,
because when we get to
that grade up there,
I'm gonna put you in the dust.
(man chuckling)
- I can go.
(man laughing)
- So let's talk about the
training a little bit.
You know, what is the structure to it?
What is the philosophy of
the day in day out approach?
You know,
walk us through what that looks like.
- Yeah, so I've,
I try to have a long term
approach on my training,
and on my race, and on my career.
So I don't have like a day to day running.
I don't like to have any routine,
and I can't because I built
my life totally different
than normal runner or professional runner,
because you know what it
means to have some kids.
(man chuckling)
But with three kids,
I have like now nine,
seven, and three years old.
- It's amazing you have
time to do anything.
- I want to be there.
I want to be there with
them and with my wife.
We want to have some common
project about the wine,
about creating an event,
about different things.
So it's what I want.
It's not just, okay,
you can just be a professional.
Yes, if I want, I can be
a professional runner.
And if I don't want any kids,
we can make these choice,
but we don't want that.
We want to have a normal life,
a social life.
We want to have kids, a family story.
We want to have a real job
and to spend some time with that.
Then okay, I know that.
So I have to train when I have time.
And I know that, yes,
before Hardrock I will have
to spend some long days
in mountains,
so that's why I'm here like
two weeks before the race.
That's why I will live in Raylan Island
like two weeks now before the race
because I have to race to beat myself.
I have to focus more on my training.
But, but yes,
I just know that,
okay, two months before a long race
you have to spend more
long days in the mountain.
You have to train
specifically for each race.
Like for Hardrock,
I know that one of the
most important thing
is altitude training.
So I don't run that much
like during, since the last two months,
but I spent a lot of
time in high mountain,
it wasn't Skimo, it wasn't climbing,
it was something like that.
And I think if I compare to last year,
I run even less,
but I spend more time in high altitude.
So, I think it's maybe a
good thing for Hardrock.
And if I have to go to Raylan
Island at the end of the year,
I know that it's totally different,
and I would have to focus
more on distance training,
something like that to,
there's a lot of stairs in that island,
so I have to walk with big
steps or something like that.
And I try to think like
six months or five months
before the race,
okay, what will be specific on that race?
And then every day, every night,
every training you think about that,
okay, what I'm actually doing,
it's important for next race,
or it's no matter,
so I try to don't that.
- Right, right.
- And yes, and then I have,
yes, I try to respect lot the season
and the condition in the mountain,
so that's why I choose
that kind of season.
Actually that's starting my
running season with autumn
it's just perfect for me
because there's a lot of
snow from December to May
where I live.
So it's hard to be ready
for race in April or May
because it mean that
you have to take the car
to go in the valley to train.
And this is what not what I love.
It's what I love is running for my door,
or skiing from my door.
- [Rich] Yeah.
- So it's easier for me
to practice some Skimo
from January to May.
And I think it's a
very, very good training
for endurance training and for,
it has strategy for summer,
then you have to back on running
slowly and progressively.
And I have all the months
of April, May, and June
to back on running progressively,
so it's just perfect
for race, like mid July.
So that's why I choose
that kind of strategy
since three to four years now.
- [Rich] Right.
- Just because I know,
okay, if I have to train
in March in running,
(man huffing)
it would be hard for to get
the motivation in Monterey,
so that's why I try to
adapt my strategy like that
and to think;
like long time ago with
my wife, with my friends,
with my partner,
with my current doctor was,
okay, I will do it next year.
So I have to focus mid-July,
I have to focus mid-October,
so I have to plan everything around that.
So even about the product development,
the family events, the
socials, the holidays,
everything,
I try to planning in November and December
and then it's way easier
to train and try everything
because with my family,
we know with the kids and
family since last year,
since one month, one year ago,
that you can plan-
- Yeah,
you can plan way ahead.
Yeah, exactly.
- End of June.
It's not like if I say
to them one week ago,
it will be so hard for them.
But now, since one year we prepare that,
since one year we know that,
okay, it will be hard for them and for me
to be without each other
during three weeks.
So we have to plan some strategies.
We visit some friends,
some family,
we have some stage,
we have some different thing
and we prepare us many things,
so it's easier and we
wait that moment finally
and we will be so happy to
meet each other in three weeks.
So it just,
if if you plan it since
one year or even more,
it's so easy.
But if you don't stay true to your people,
or you, okay.
(man chuckling)
- See ya later.
- In one month,
I have my biggest race
of my life and bye bye.
(man groaning)
It's so hard.
(man chuckling)
So this is my,
it's not like I don't
know if I answer very well
to your question,
it's not my strategic of training,
but planning things like that,
I think it's a key point of the training
because then you just have to say,
okay, we keep some free time for that.
We plan this event, or
this event, and this event,
and finally your training
is nearly done like that.
Because now I'm here two
weeks now before Hardrock.
I finish all my product development.
I'm just without family.
I just have time for me.
- [Rich] Right.
- What will you do
when you are in the mountain
just with free time for you?
It's training.
- Right.
- [Francois] It's easy to train.
- There is something counterintuitive,
but kind of undeniable
about having a full life
outside of your life as an athlete.
You know, you would think
you would enhance your
performance by living like a monk
in a cabin alone,
and just waking up in the morning
and going out and training all day
with no distractions year round.
And perhaps you could
get a great performance
in the short term,
but you know, the more I speak to you,
the more I realize how deeply
you think about longevity.
It's more about trying to
be the best that you can be
for the longest period of time.
And in order to do that,
you have to have diversity in your life.
You have to be living your life.
You can't be putting aside
things that you want in your life
for the sake of performance.
So to have three kids,
to have this full life
where you're engaged in your community,
and your previous career as a winemaker,
which I want to talk about,
like all of those things
feel like they would detract
from your performances.
But my sense is that all of those things
ultimately enhance your performance.
They fuel your life
because you're a happy, grounded person
with interests outside of just running.
- Yeah, it's true.
But it's true too that you are more tired
and it's not easy to train every day.
And some, I actually it was a,
I have a very hard moments
of moments of June,
and I discuss a lot
with Jim and say, okay,
(man sighing)
okay, you don't have any kids.
He's just in France for training.
You have just to wake up,
make his coffee.
- Yeah.
- And then thinking,
oh, where can I go today to train?
And you wake up at six in the
morning because baby's crying,
then you have to take kids to school,
then you have then a partner,
and media to do.
And then if you have
time you can go to train,
but you have too many things to do.
Ah, okay, it's too much.
How can I prepare from like that?
But on those other things,
you think about what you say,
it's okay, this is my life.
I choose that one,
and it's helped me a lot.
So it's never easy to have this background
and to have a,
but I think for me everybody's different.
But for me it was very
important since the beginning.
And we discuss a lot of that with my wife
to have a balanced life,
to have this different pillar,
to like, okay, a family,
social,
the job, the sport, everything,
and sport is important,
but for me,
I try to never put it a most
important thing in my life.
I always try to have some background.
Okay, it's just a pleasure,
it's just a passion,
and I think having kids
and something for me
was always more important than everything,
because if you focus too much on sport,
okay, one year, it's everything works.
Okay, it's perfect.
But if it's doing 10 years,
then 10 years you look beside you,
you look around you and say,
okay, since 10 year I focus on that.
And finally I don't have any kids
and I don't really everything for me.
I think it's-
- When your whole sense of identity
is wrapped up in your performances.
- Yeah, I think, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
With respect to the training,
I've heard you say
something along the lines of
it's more important,
the frequency of your
trainings is more important
than the length of your trainings.
Like there's this idea,
if you're gonna be an ultra runner,
you gotta go out and
run for 12 hours a day
every single day, right?
And I think you've said your longer runs
are really kind of in the
six to seven hour range.
You'll go out for those longer days of,
as you mentioned earlier,
just being in the mountains, Skimo,
or just, you know,
kind of hiking or whatever
it is to experience altitude.
But in terms of the running,
my sense is that you're
careful not to overdo it
and go into that kind
of over training zone
where you can get injured or burnt out.
- I try to always have
some pain somewhere.
And I actually have some difficulty
with some part of my body,
but I try to make some cycling,
and to make different things,
and I try to never push too much
to be over training or injured.
So yes, I try to do that.
But yes,
it's kind of part of my training too
to say, okay, I wake up,
my second kid,
he wake up like eight times each night
until he are three years.
- Wow.
(man laughing)
- So you can say,
okay, I'm too tried and I cannot train.
Or you can say, okay, I will train.
- You're training when you're tired
is kind of a good thing.
- But yes, I was thinking that.
I was thinking, okay, I'm so tired,
but I have to train.
But when you are on a
new trail after 20 hour,
what do you think?
You are tired too.
So if you never train when you are tired,
you will never have this feeling.
So me say, okay, I will
train with less intensity
of course,
maybe we less energy of course,
but I will train anyway even if I'm tired,
even if I drink too much the day before,
if I made too much party even.
Okay, it's even if I eat too much,
even if just I have my breakfast.
Okay.
You have to test everything
because in your trail
you will meet everything.
And in trail, what we said
earlier is that you cannot,
you can plan everything,
but you will have to adapt everything.
- [Rich] Yeah.
- Because this is why
we made ultra.
If we know what will happen,
we can make athletes more
cross country or some loop.
But no, we go in the mountain,
in high mountain
just because we want to
have something different.
We will have to adapt ourself,
and that's why I think my life,
maybe it's good for ultra distance
because okay, this morning we're in US,
we want to train,
your scrambled eggs and
bacon and everything.
But then okay, we will run.
Okay, but I won't have to
wait three hours for running
and I have to train directly,
so, oh, okay.
I feel ill, I feel thirsty.
Okay, I feel a bit
tired about the jet lag.
Okay.
But if I have to wait that
everything is correct to run,
okay, I will run in one week.
So no, it's not good.
So, okay, yesterday we arrive,
we have a 24 day of traveling,
but okay, I'm in Boulder.
I'm happy to be there.
I would like to discover the mountain,
so I go there for two hour run.
For sure I don't have the
best feeling of my life,
even the worst feeling of my life.
I sweat a lot.
I don't have any poor, but-
- This is the thing though.
- I think this is the thing,
and this is really a good
training I think for ultra,
because you have to adapt,
you have to feel what's
happening in your body,
how you can answer,
and readapt and make things,
and finally I was able to run two hours.
And I think it's a good thing.
But if your whole life is well planned
to always be at the best
possibility for your training,
when you arrive in ultra, you don't.
- You're gonna be waiting for a long time.
- You don't know how to do, yeah.
- Right.
Right, you're missing the whole point.
- [Francois] Yeah.
- All right.
- Of course, when you arrive
in Colorado after 10 hour,
middle of the night,
of course your legs are destroyed.
Of course you run 10 hour
too fast with descent,
ascent,
and then it's middle of the night,
of course you feel tired
and you don't know what's happened
because you don't want to eat.
Of course, because it's
middle of the night,
nobody eats at the middle of the night.
- [Rich] Yeah.
- So you don't feel
comfortable.
But if your body was
never in that position,
you don't know how to do.
But if your body was, okay,
I remember I did that,
or I have this same feeling,
or okay, I can do it because
I have the experience
that I can,
then you continue
and then you can be a
better part of yourself
and even win the race.
But that's why I think my
life is not finally so bad
for ultra training.
- Right.
- Maybe for altitude, and performance,
and short distance training,
but for ultra?
- Every training session,
you're combating an obstacle, right?
- [Francois] Yeah.
- Just to get out the door.
- Exactly.
- Yeah, that is a really
interesting lens to look at it.
How has your training
evolved over the years?
I mean, with every win or miss,
you know, all of these accomplishments
you're learning along the way,
and I assume refining, figuring
out what works for you,
what doesn't,
Did you do anything different this year
leading up to Hardrock
versus leading up to Hardrock last year?
- Yeah, of course.
I try to,
normally I never did a race from one year
to the next year directly
because you have too many
elements of comparison
and it's too hard for me.
- [Rich] Yeah.
- And you put
too much pressure.
But it's a bits a game of the Hardrock.
But when you want it,
then it's interesting to
come back the year after
because you run with all the way
for the community.
I think it's very nice to come back
and I'm so happy to be there again.
So I have to compose with that.
But yes, last year I feel
that the altitude training,
it's something very important,
so that I was really
focused a bit more on that.
And I tried to build some
project around Mont Blanc,
which is highest mountain in Europe,
but the condition were
not so good this year
because it was really dry.
So I made some more, some rock climbing.
We go to in Switzerland and Italy.
Apennine seven,
I don't know if you knows this mountain,
but it's a very great mountain.
And we spent some more than
20 hour above 4,000 meters.
And I did Mont Blanc Skimo
and I went a lot like that.
So I think altitude training,
and I'm better than last year.
But just about training,
I think because it's a life,
and we try to create an event with my wife
for next September.
It's first edition.
So I was not thinking
that it will take this
amount of time to us,
and so I don't have the time
that I was thinking to have
for training, just for running.
So I think I'm a bit less
trained than last year
in training,
and even more in decent
because of the,
we enjoy to spend many
times around this event,
and to discuss about that,
and we really want to make something.
Yes, something good
and something very linked with our values.
So it was very important for us.
It was one of our priority
this past two months.
So I hope I will, it will be okay.
And we still have like
10 days for training,
so I hope it'll be okay,
but I think that I'm
more trained on altitude,
but less trained just
in the running capacity.
- Right, got it.
So yes, you have this new race
that you and your wife have
created called Ultra Spirit?
- Yes.
- Ultra Spirit,
which is coming up in September,
early September, right?
- [Francois] Yes.
- Which is exciting.
You're creating your own race.
It's a couple races between
25 and 50 kilometers
in your region where you live.
And this is a new kind of
entrepreneurial journey.
Prior to that you were a winemaker,
which I want to get into,
but what inspired you
to create your own race?
- It's a bit like a of consequence
of why we stop the winery,
and yes, for us it was
really important to,
it's not really a race,
it's more like an event
I think, ultra distance,
because we were thinking,
okay, like in five years or 10 years,
if we want to do
something in the mountain,
something organized in the
mountain, what it will be?
And we were thinking,
I'm not sure we'll go again in UTMB,
maybe yes.
Or I'm not sure we'll go
again a classical for trail.
I think we would like to be together
to share something like as a team.
We would like to have some good moment
with the other participant.
Even with the organizer.
We would like to be in total
immersion with the territory
and the specialty,
and we won't like to
discover like very deeply
the place where we are,
and to have some fun,
learn the basics, which is ultra trail.
So we say, okay, we
actually organize something,
like who can answer out of that.
And we were thinking just,
okay, what could be very nice for us
in five years to have,
and then we organize that event.
- Yeah, and so it's a
team based thing, right?
- [Francois] Yes.
- 25 teams,
three people on a team.
- Yeah.
- [Rich] Is it like a relay,
or you run together with your teammates?
- No, no, no.
You start together, and
you finish together,
and you sleep together,
and you eat together,
and you sleep in a tent of three people
without any shower during two days.
So it'll be a-
- It's like a reality show.
- It will be a very nice
experience for three people.
But with the team, between the team too,
I think because this year
we start just with 25 team,
and I think that will be
some very good relationship
in the,
and will be interesting.
And one thing interesting too is that,
okay, performance is important,
and the time of running
will be important too,
but I think what is the most important
is to to be in the mountain,
to discover yourself,
to discover your team,
to discover each other.
So that's why everybody will
run the same amount of time.
So you will start the Friday for six hour,
then you will have 11 hour on Saturday,
and then you are five
hour again on the Sunday.
So it will be around
20, 21 hour of running
during the weekend,
which it's not nothing.
But it's not like 21 hour in one time.
And everybody will run
the same amount of time,
which is very difficult
for us as organizer,
because you have to
think that the first team
will run faster than the last team.
- [Rich] Yeah.
- So they will make some
different loop to arrive
all together at the end.
We would like that people
arrive in less than 30 minutes.
So it would be very
interesting to organize it,
and yeah, I hope it would
be fun for the people
and we will make some different
activity at the middle.
Like, you arrive at
the top on the mountain
and you arrive to make a game
just to understand what is the difference
between the summer trees
and the winter trees,
which is impossible at
the middle of a race.
But then if you are not able to do that,
you will have a penalty of 25 minutes.
- Ah!
The twist.
- Yes.
People will say, okay, no
matter if I run fast or not,
I most have to focus on my test.
(man laughing)
And so it would be interesting
because you will have
like 10 games like that
during the three days.
- That's cool.
- And during the day, during the night.
And I think it's really
different than a normal race.
- So you could be the fastest runners,
but if you fail all those, you won't,
other tests.
- Yeah,
you wont won the competition.
- Right.
(man laughing)
That's a great spin on the whole thing.
- And we try to make something
that even if you are the
faster and the stronger runner,
it's not sure that you will win the game.
The game not only on the spot think.
- Right.
Yeah, I like that approach.
I, just the other day I did a
podcast with Malcolm Gladwell,
who's a writer.
I don't know if you're familiar with him,
but he's also, he's super into running,
and he always is thinking
about ways to change the way
that we do sports to make
them more interesting.
And he had this idea that high
school cross country teams
it should be reconfigured such that
it's not about whoever wins
the race for that team,
but it's the combined time of like,
you know, the 10 people on the team.
So the slowest person on the
team is just as important
as the fastest.
And so everybody, you're
incentivized as a team
to cheer for the least talented person
or the least well trained
person on your team,
which is similar to the
idea that you just shared.
Like, how can you even the playing field
and make it kind of up
for grabs for anybody?
It's not just about the best athlete.
- Yeah, and it's even we vote TVT.
If you run in a team of three,
I think the best team will not be
the team of the best free runner.
It will be the team
who will take care the
most of the third runner.
- [Rich] Right.
- Because the third runner,
the slowest runner, is
the most important one.
And if you don't take care of each other,
you will be not able to finish.
- Doesn't matter.
(man laughing)
- And that's why, even at
the registration I say,
okay, you have to stop at
least 25 minutes for everybody.
With that, the registration
will be more cool moments,
family can come,
and you have time to discover,
and to discuss with each other,
and you will have time to
take care of the third runner.
If doing 25 minutes,
you don't take care of the
those person of your group.
I think it's a mistake,
because if you arrive
the first runner is easy.
He can, yes, change your shoes.
Edge out the runner,
even made a message,
or okay, ask and change
the nutrition strategy,
and help him,
and it will,
it can change a lot
because I think it's very
important to know that
because then if they want to make a ultra,
they will have more
experience and more idea
about what can happen in ultra.
And I think all the activity,
it looks like, okay, tasting your cheese.
This is no, no, no, no.
- Nothing to do with it.
- Nothing to do with it, yeah.
But finally,
if you think each activity
will have a sense for yourself,
for your team,
and for your experience,
and your way in ultra.
And that's what we would
like to to show to people
at the end,
is that, okay, you did 10 activities,
you did three days,
you don't need an ultra,
but we, all of that,
I think for your next ultra
you will be more ready.
- Right.
And it makes it more fun.
So that person who's trying
something for the first time
will have a positive experience
that will make them enthusiastic
about learning more.
- We hope so.
We will have fun,
and we hope that they will have fun too,
otherwise we missed something.
(man laughing)
- So this is,
you know, a lot of people
perhaps expected you
to show up at UTMB again
and go for a fifth win.
These dates coincide.
That makes that impossible.
Is it,
was that I assume this is why
you're not participating in UTMB,
or is it just like I did that.
I don't need to go back there.
What is your relationship to that race?
- I'm not sure I will
go back into the future
because I did already five times,
and I win it four times,
and I did three times CCCs.
I'm not sure I will go back to UTMB.
I cannot promise it 100%,
but maybe I will go back
and a bit different,
and with some other people.
I don't know.
But for sure it's not my goal
to to be the first to win it five times,
or six time, or even four times.
Because last year everybody say,
oh, you are here to be the
first to win it four times.
Okay, if you want.
But not really.
- That wasn't your motivation.
- No, no, no.
It's not my motivation.
And I think that's why I win it four time.
It's just because it
was not my motivation.
But no, for me, trail running
means some different things.
Some travel, some
discovering some other race.
And I think there's many,
many, many races in the world,
and yeah, I think it's,
UTMB's, it's important.
It's a very nice race, an incredible race.
And even if people say,
ah, it's too crowded.
Now there's too much people.
And it's a big race, a big mess.
Okay, Chamonix is Chamonix.
UTMB's UTMB,
and even River Race,
when we go to race when you are here,
and you say, okay, you have to cross
three different country,
you have to make a loop
around this amazing mountain.
It's amazing.
It's very wonderful and
I really enjoy that,
that part of France and of the Alp.
And yeah, for me it's, when I think UTMB,
it's very good memories.
And for sure I will be
there again one time,
but I'm not sure I will
race again to win it,
because I did it,
and I have many, many other goals,
and I want to to discover something else,
and to travel and to
make something different.
- [Rich] Yeah.
- And I have many, many plans
in my head for the next few runs.
- Yeah.
Well, I think it's cool
that you're always kind
of iterating and growing,
and not afraid to kind
of let go of things,
to try new things.
Which kind of brings up
the wine making thing.
I mean, for years your wife and
yourself were creating wine,
right?
In Beaujolais region.
You've since moved to the mountains.
But talk a little bit about that.
Like, that's a world I
know very little about,
but feels like it would be an
all consuming kind of affair
to create great wine.
- Yeah, it was.
It was very,
and for UTMB, it just a smaller
joke I would like to add.
It's just that I start,
I don't want to go back to UTMB
because I really would like
that an American winner
could win it for the first time.
- Oh.
(men laughing)
That's very sweet of you.
That's the pull quote.
We'll take that out.
That's that's the thing
you're gonna get quoted on.
(man chuckling)
- I just-
- Any American in particular
you might be thinking of?
- It's no, I called the American runner,
but yes, I have one of
them not far from my house,
and I hope he could be.
- I think he's doing everything
in his power right now
to make that happen just for you.
- Sure.
And now, but the wine was,
yeah, the one was really passionate,
but to be honest,
at the beginning we were
not thinking that this job
is so passionate, and so complete,
and so different every day.
We were just thinking that okay,
we like each other with my wife.
We get married since
11 years, two days ago.
- [Rich] Ah, great.
(man chuckling)
- So, yeah,
we are really close,
and we want to build something together,
but we were thinking, okay, I'm physio.
I'm an international runner.
She works from an array.
I work on my way.
There's too many things and
we never see each other,
and it's not the way that
we want to spend our life,
so we have to have a common project.
And what we like is to be out,
to be the natural,
to feel the terre.
I don't know if it's a good word.
- The land.
- [Francois] Yeah, the land.
- The soil.
- And the roots.
And it's very important for us.
And so we were thinking maybe
we will have some animals,
maybe we would have a
bed and breakfast house,
and share something
with the people locally
and something like that.
And maybe we can have this possibility
to make this winery.
It's an old story.
We were family,
but not as close as we think,
but it's helped a lot for us.
But we were thinking, okay, animals,
you have to be there every day.
And bed and breakfast,
exactly the same.
And we have international runner careers
that may be possible.
So maybe the winery
could be the best option.
And that's why we say, okay,
we will try this option.
And then we discover this.
We knew that we like the wine,
we like to taste some different wine
even when we are in US or in France.
It's just so interesting to see that.
Okay, in Zataria it's totally different.
Zataria, there's a history
from this version to this version.
And we are really
fascinated about the taste,
and about the finning, and
the history, and everything.
So we knew that it would be something that
very passion for us.
But then we had discovered
that each season
is totally different,
and each moment of the
season is totally different
because you have to
focus on commercializing,
of communication,
of creating the bottles,
on the vinification,
on the worker,
on the vineyard.
And each moment it's totally different.
And it was so helpful for
us to discover everything
and to play with that.
So it was a, a full, full, full-time job.
But it was so interesting,
and we have an amazing
10 years on the vineyard,
and yes, we really enjoy that,
and we developed some many,
many project about that
during the pandemic.
We developed something
like bit more ecological.
It's to bring the wine from
the valley to the mountain
by foot instead of helicopter.
- Oh wow.
- [Francois] It was very interesting.
Very hard.
- Yeah.
But very interesting.
But this project, even if we stop,
we want to continue it.
And I was there last Monday,
like two days ago,
to bring two different during the day,
and it was like eight hour working
with 30 kilo on your backpack.
And it's so interesting to
bring the wine from the valley
to the earth,
even if some other things
that came to by agriculture,
at least the wine came back by foot.
- The idea is that for
sustainability reasons,
or just to say this is possible?
- It's not just for sustainability,
but it's just to show the people
you bring directly from the producer,
to the consumer,
and even it's true that
there's a sustainability part.
It's really important for us,
but it's just people, they
will take a glass of wine,
they know from where the wine is coming.
They know how the wine
is coming to the earth
and then you are with your
friends in the mountain
with the sunset.
Take your glass of wine.
I think it's a totally different wine.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I can see that.
And I know you were growing,
you're doing it organic, or
at least one of the wines
was organic.
- Yeah,
it was one of the things
that why we have to stop
is because it's a lot of cost.
- It's a lot harder to do that.
- We are not the owner of the land,
and it's maybe too much money to continue
in our way for them,
and then with the kids.
And it was too,
it means too much traveling
for me from the mountain place
where we are actually to the Beaujolais.
So it's many, many things that we say,
okay, we did it for 11 years,
maybe it's time to switch
from something else,
and we really want to focus on that event.
So it's many, many reasons that we change,
but this kind of project we resort,
we want to continue it
because it is very, very interesting.
And yeah, tonight,
I don't know if you will taste it tonight,
but I have some wine for you.
Maybe you will taste it with your family.
- We'll see.
- [Francois] To enjoy it.
(man chuckling)
- It's,
well that's a different conversation,
about my relationship with wine.
But anyway,
Beaujolais is,
I mean it's not that
far from Geneva, right?
It's fairly close, but you're
not in the mountains, right?
- So you in US, it's not far.
(men laughing)
- Yeah,
it looks close on the map to me.
For you, you think it's like.
It's a couple hours in the car, right?
- Yeah, two hours, yes.
- [Rich] That's nothing.
- No, it's not that big, but.
- But for you to train day in a day after.
- The mountain is totally different, yes.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So instead of having to go
back and forth with the kids,
it's like, let's simplify our lives.
You moved to the mountains.
- Yeah, because it means
that we were living
in the Beaujolais place
and in the Beaujolais place
at a different moment of the year,
so they have to change the
school two times a year.
And for them it's,
I can understand that it's a bit hard,
and yes, many, many reason.
And now we live yes, in a small village
in the heart of the Alps.
And for training it's
really, really better for me.
And I think for life it's more sustainable
and it's more interesting for us.
And yeah, it was,
it was hard for when you
change something in your life.
It's always hard to make the move.
But I think we are happy
with our new choice
and I hope we will enjoy
it for a long time.
Yeah.
- And from a parenting perspective,
I mean, and your kids are still so young,
but to kind of raise them in
that mountain environment,
you know, I would assume on some level
you're exposing them to this,
the kind of activities that you love.
They'll grow up with that.
They'll have their own minds
about what they want to do
of course,
but you have a sense of whether
one or more of your kids
is prone to the kind of things
that you like to do?
Or is it too early to tell?
- Yeah, we don't want to
push themself too much
on what we did and on
the competition approach,
because already people do it for us.
Are you like your father?
You will do that?
- No, no, no.
- No.
- [Francois] We try to.
- It never works out
like that.
- But it's true
that they don't have a TV at home.
It's true that they're
always, always in the nature.
- Outdoors.
- In the mountain,
and there's not too many cars,
and there's,
yes, it's a totally different life
that if you live in a city for sure,
and it's a very small school.
There's not too many children
and they all know each other,
and yeah,
during winter times they ski
like two times or three
times a week with the school
and two times or three
times a week with the club
and one time with me,
so it means that they can
ski like six times a week.
It's just, yes.
- Yeah.
- It's sure that they,
for sure they will be
fascinated about snow,
about mountain,
about everything,
and yeah, when they
came with us to the hut,
they are so happy to sleep in the hut
and they already made like
800 meters elevation gain
at six years old
because I have three box
of wines on my backpack,
so they know that I cannot rail them.
So it's okay,
I have to go by myself
because my father have
already four box of wine.
So they did it finally.
And sometimes they even
did it faster than us
because we four box of wine.
(man laughing)
Not so easy.
So, yeah.
- [Rich] That's cool.
- It's sure that, yeah, they enjoy,
I hope they enjoy their
life in the mountain,
but yeah, they have smiles every day,
so it's okay.
- That's cool.
And the wine, even though
you're not doing it anymore,
I mean there's still,
you have plenty of wine
still to sell, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- For years to come.
So do you have that available
at some of these races in Europe?
Like, how do you distribute that?
- Yeah, we try to just
make direct selling,
so directly to the people.
So we choose like three
to four event every year,
not too much,
because it's important for
us to take time to discuss
and to spend some time with people.
So it's been a lot of energy.
So we just choose like four
to five event every year
to sell it and to share
it with the people.
But yeah,
I think for the next two to three years
we have the possibility to still sell it.
And we made some different
trail runner box every year.
So we made the last one
and we will be releasing
that in two months, I think.
It'll be ready for the end of the season.
And it's a very interesting one that,
we try to relate all the
history of the last 10 years.
It's a mix between running
and creating the wine.
So we made a lot of jug
and instruction about that.
So for us, it's a bit emotional
that this last box.
- Yeah, so running and drinking wine
combined into one experience.
- Yes.
- [Rich] Yeah.
And normally for people,
it's not a,
it's not like a good runner approach
or a good athlete approach.
But now we discuss a lot together
and you can understand that
finally with my way to train
and my way to life,
it's not impossible to have a winery
and to drink a glass of wine
at the end of your training
and be a top athlete.
Because I think it's important to say
that if you spend 10
hours in the mountain,
then okay,
you can arrive and drink nothing
and just eat some veggies
and going to sleep,
or otherwise, you can
say, okay, I run 10 hour,
and it was a very good training,
and I was with some
friends in the mountain,
and now I have to have a
social moment with them.
It could be a coffee, or
glass of wine, or beer,
or whatever you want,
but for me it's important to say,
okay, it was amazing day.
And then when you will be in the race,
and if you think, okay,
is that training of 10 hour,
then I said to my friend,
no, I cannot come with you
because I have to make my compacts,
and I have to sleep early,
and I have to do nothing,
and you will remember when
it'll be a hard moment doing so,
okay.
It'll be hard training
and then I don't have a
good moment with my friends.
I was by myself in my room
and it was hard again,
or you can remember, okay,
it was a hard training,
but it was so good training,
and then I have a so nice
moment with some friends,
and we have a nice dinner
and we have a nice moment.
Wow, it was so good.
And then you have a positive attitude
and you can continue,
and for me, it's my approach to say, okay,
okay, it's hard,
but I know it'll be hard,
but at least I have this very
nice training in my back,
and it's so good to think
about that at this moment.
So that's why I try to enjoy that.
And that's why I say to people, okay,
I won't say to you drink a bottle of wine
just one hour before the race,
but like one week before
or even two months before
when I saw people, no, I
cannot taste your wine.
I have UTMB in three months.
I say, wow, three months before the race,
you don't want to taste the wine?
One glass of my wine?
Okay, maybe you push too much restraint.
- Yeah, exactly.
And it goes back to what we
were talking at the beginning
about longevity in your career.
You have to enjoy what you're doing,
if you're gonna stay in it.
And ultimately the more
you're enjoying this pursuit,
as hard as it is,
the the kind of higher
you'll be able to reach,
you know?
But to live under such a
strict kind of rule book,
maybe you have one great year,
but in five years you're not
gonna wanna do it anymore.
- I think if it's too hard for you body,
it's not good.
But everybody's different.
Some people they like to
have a life like that,
like athlete life,
and they can do it for
a decade no problem.
And I know some athlete like that,
and even Killian,
I think his passion is not
about food, or social moment,
or something like that,
but his passion is like that.
But people will say, I really like wine,
but I cannot have a glass of wine
because in six months I will do this race.
How can this kind of people
continue this for 20 years?
It's impossible.
- [Rich] Sure.
- Because, for me, it's not possible.
So you have to be well
balanced with what you think,
what you feel, and what you love,
and then you can think about longevity,
and I think for short distance
it's a different thing,
but for a long distance,
I think it's the best
approach to be well balanced
and to enjoy what you do every day.
I think it's very, very important for me.
- And so how old are you now, 36?
- Yes.
- 36.
So how long do you imagine yourself
being competitive in the sport?
- I hope for many years,
but yes, I try to do what I love,
and I don't want to change my way of life.
So if in five years, I don't know,
the level increase a lot,
and another one on one mys
became more and more athletic,
and more and more competition,
and more like you have
to change your life,
and stop to have a normal life and family
beside your training to
be able to reach the top.
It's no matter for me, I will continue.
I hope I will continue
and I will do it again.
Maybe not as the first position,
but I don't want to stop running
and I don't want to stop traveling
and discovering some new races
and meet a community like that.
- [Rich] Yeah.
- And to have some project,
but maybe I won't be the
top in five to 10 years,
but I'm sure I will,
I'm able to continue to progress.
Maybe I will progress less
than the top competitors,
but I'm sure I'm able
to continue to progress
because I think I
continue to experience my,
yes, my life.
And I'm sure I will have
some new things to discover.
- Right.
You've created a life that's
conducive to the training,
but also to the kind of
joyful pursuit of all,
like everything seems like
it's in a nice balance
that will allow you to
con continue to do it.
Whether you're able to
be on a podium or not
almost feels secondary from
the way that you explained it.
- Yeah.
And since, I don't know, maybe 10 years,
no, but, yeah, I think 10 years now,
I try to have some project
inclusive-
- Other things.
- Of the races.
And I did, we discussed a lot
about that with Jim Walmsley
and some of the runner,
and I'm sure even if it's not on the race
or on classical race,
I'm sure I would be able to
continue some different project.
I never been in Himalaya
and I think it's some incredible mountain
and some incredible project to do race in,
and I'm really passionated when I,
I heard a story about No
Lands not far from there,
and it'll be so interesting
to make it like differently,
with Jim maybe
to spend some hours in the mountain,
like for 25 or 30 or 40 hours
in the mountain together.
And yeah, I discuss with Jim.
He joined me on the Pacific Crest,
on the John Muir Trail in 2017.
Jim was with me on the
Pacific Crest try in 2019.
And it's so interesting,
and there's a cool other
trail just over there.
And I have ton of project
that I would like to do
in trail running,
and I think it's the most
important goal for me.
Is more important than winning that race.
That race is just, wow,
what I have to do in the next 10 years.
Plenty of things, I think.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Before we kind of round this out,
there are plenty of runners
that listen to this show,
and aspiring runners,
people who are thinking about
perhaps their first trail race
or their first ultra marathon,
so I thought it would be
great if you could share
maybe some wisdom around
what are some common
mistakes that people make
that you see in training
for their first race,
or in being kind of maybe too afraid
to sign up for something
that seems impossible to do?
Like, how do you think about that?
Or you know, what would
you say to that person?
- Yeah, I think the progression
is something very, very important.
I know that maybe it's
because of the media,
the people to say the grand,
and things to do is 100 miles,
but you cannot start your running career
with 10K and one year later at
the start line of 100 miles.
Yes, you can do it,
and maybe you can finish it,
but if you think longevity,
if you think progression,
how you can sprint from 10K
to 100 miles in one year.
Yes, if you take a look at that,
if you have a look on that,
it's not just possible.
So I think the progression
is really, really important,
and to think that yes,
you have time to do it
because for me, 100 miles is the dream.
So if you achieve your dream too fast,
then okay, you can have some other dream.
But if it's a big dream,
no matter if it take you one
year, or two year, three year,
five years maybe
it's maybe a better dream
if it take long time
to achieve it in.
So I think it's very important
to have this kind of progression,
to have different test,
to have different history,
to take time to meet the people,
to discover yourself, to test.
Yeah, I, we have, my partner,
we work since 10 years
to develop the product
and to test the product.
So it's so interesting to test
these kind of bags of shoes.
What is better for us,
and the nutrition
strategy, and everything,
I think it's so interesting
to test everything,
so people have to take
time to test everything,
to test themselves,
to discover themselves before
going to the 100 miles,
but the second thing that
you say is true, that's, wow,
100 miles.
It looks like impossible, but not.
I think 100 miles is even
more possible than a marathon,
because in marathon you have
the perspective of performance
enough time.
And maybe New York Marathon
it's a bit different
because it's, okay,
I just want to do New York
Marathon no matter the time.
But normally people in marathon,
running marathons,
they want to put time.
On one on one, no one tell of time.
You just want to finish it.
For the first one that
was the last runner.
It's the same goal,
it's just to achieve this
adventure and this journey.
And it's so hard and so interesting to do.
But it's not impossible,
because it could be just walking,
just running.
And if you go it slowly,
I'm sure it's possible,
but you have to be really
passionate about that
and you have to know why you do that.
If you are at the start
line of one 100 mile race,
just because it's a bet with your friend,
or just because you dream-
- You're in trouble.
- And you say, okay,
I made this bet with my
friend and now I'm here,
but I'm not sure I want to be there.
Okay, don't take the start
because running 100 mile
it must be something that
you feel in your heart,
and you are really motivated about that
because of course it'll be hard,
but if you know why you are here,
if it's a dream,
I'm sure it's possible to do.
- Hmm, yeah.
Knowing your why and patience, right?
That idea of progression
really is about patience.
I think so many people really overestimate
what they can do in a year,
and they bite off more than they can chew
and then find out quickly enough
that maybe that wasn't possible.
And then they give up,
and they miss the greater opportunity,
which is understanding what's
possible with persistence
and patience over an
extended period of time.
Maybe it's 10 years, but-
- Yeah, even for me.
- Something you slowly,
slowly iterate on it
in that really non-sexy way
that no one's paying attention to,
that's truly how you
accomplish these goals
that seem audacious.
- Yeah, I think I start
running long distance
in just, yes.
- I mean,
were you a guy who won your
first races right out of the bat
and were just winning
everything that you entered?
- No, no, no, no.
It's even for me,
and I was able to win some big ultra race,
it's taken me 10 years to do it.
So 10 years is not nothing.
So I'm sure I can do it in 4, 5, 6 years,
but yes,
4, 5, 6 years for people it's too long,
but I think it's not a big
deal to make the 100 mile race,
is not nothing.
And if you consider it like, oh, okay,
it's just 100 mile race,
you say I can do it,
so I will do it in one year.
No, I think it's not the
good approach 100 mile race.
It's not nothing.
And if you think it's nothing,
it'll be too hard for you.
- Right.
(man laughing)
That's a very wise thing to say.
Yeah,
I mean how about just start with,
can you go out and walk
around a mountain all day,
you know, like instead of thinking about
how fast you can run,
and how long you can
sustain a certain pace.
- Yeah, I think it's a
best thing say just to say,
okay, no matter the pace,
no matter the elevation,
no matter the distance and
everybody say about training,
what is your mileage?
What is the distance you do each week?
I say, I don't know.
(man chuckling)
Even for my event that we
will create in September,
we don't want to give the distance.
We will say to people,
okay, you will have to spend
five to six hours in mountain.
Yeah, but what is the distance?
I don't know.
(man laughing)
It's,
maybe I can give you elevation gain,
maybe I can say you some
different thing, but I don't know.
It will depend your pace,
it will depend the forecast,
it will depend some terrain, everything.
But I don't know what
would be the distance.
It's just you have to be able to spend
like six hours the first day
and eleven hours the
second day in the mountain,
and then we would see what
would be the distance.
- [Rich] Right.
- We don't know,
and I don't want to know.
- That'll drive Americans crazy.
But what's great about that
is it forces you to let go
of all of those attachments
and expectations.
Like, can you free yourself
from what you imagine it is,
or it can or will be,
and just be in the experience,
which is really what it's about, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
No, it's a good way.
- Where do you,
what do you,
you have your idea of what you
want to do with these races
that you're creating,
but where do you see the
future of trail running
and ultra running like 10 years from now?
You know, how are you thinking about
the new generation of young, ultra runners
who are coming up
and what is that world gonna look like
in the not too distant future?
- It's hard to say
because I'm so happy that
there's more, and more, and more
people practicing trail running,
but in a sustainable way.
You can say, okay,
it's more and more event,
and more and more thing organized,
and if you start a race
now you are 100 people
and in 10 years you are 10,000 people.
I think it's too much for the track,
it's too much for everything,
so that's why with the event,
and that's why I think with
the organizer and runner,
we say okay, two race
in a year, it's good.
I think it's good for the body
and it's good for the planet too,
because I can do like
10 trail run in a year,
but it's mean that 10 travel.
If you do only two,
it's already two travel.
Okay, it's a lot.
But it's only two travel for
international, national outlet.
I think it's a minimum that I have to do
to meet the community and to be there
at the top of the international race.
But it's only two races.
And that's why I try
to discuss with people
that there's only,
there's not only a life
when you have a big number.
You can make things by yourself.
And that's why in my heaven,
and that's why when I discuss with you
and something like that,
I say a lot that you have
to experience yourself alone
in the mountain to discover yourself,
to understand how,
when you go in the mountain,
you have to take care of the forecast,
of your equipment,
about the map,
about everything,
and you have to take a headlamp,
you have to take a survival blanket,
and you have to, yes, to
take care from each other
if you are in a group.
And I think it's very important.
And I think in 10 years,
I'm sure that there will
be more, and more, and more
trail runner,
but maybe less races,
and maybe people they
will do it by themselves,
and they will organize
their adventure by themself,
and with that,
there's ton of possibility and no limit
because you can imagine
your personal adventure
and what is more relevant for you.
And because may I say that my season
is from July to October,
but every place on the world are different
and every people are different,
so there's no definition of trail running
because you can do it along the coast,
you can do it in the mountain,
you can do it in the middle of-
- It's whatever you decide it to be.
- Yeah.
And me, I like when it's in the mountain,
but for some people they prefer
to do it in a single trail,
flat above the ocean.
And everybody's different
and everybody have some different tastes
or with that evolution,
everybody can build their own
adventure by themself alone,
long distance, short distance,
coast distance, mountain coast,
challenge.
And what is important
for me is that people,
they can discover themselves,
they can discover the natural,
and they're out from some
long day in the mountain
and people say,
yeah, it's not sustainable traveling,
and too many race, too many event.
Yeah, but you can just practice running
without any race,
without any event, and by yourself.
And I think it's a good approach.
I would like to say to people,
try it,
test it,
play with that.
And for me it's so passionate
since more than 20 years,
and so I'd like to push people to say,
okay, try it and you would
see it's possible to do thing
that you are not thinking it's possible.
It's just 20 years ago,
for me doing like, Hardrock 100,
it's just unbelievable, right?
And 20 years later,
I was able to want it and to
have the record on that race,
so nothing is impossible.
So you can do it.
And the victory is not just about winning,
it's just accomplish your dream.
So this is what is
interesting in trail running
and ultra distance
is that everybody has his own victory
and everybody can share the same dream
and the same adventure,
because when we are on the start line
of the Hardrock 100,
the winner of the race,
since the last winner of
the race has the same dream,
it's just to finish the loop,
and to see the mountain again.
No matter the place,
we just want to finish
it and to accomplish it.
And I think this is unique
in all of the other sport.
- Yeah, yeah.
That's really, that's beautifully put.
I mean there is this
inherent sort of paradox
with the growth of trail running,
because the roots of it,
and what is so alluring about it
is that connection with nature,
and that kind of the solitude of it all,
and the, you know, the kind of silence,
just you and your breath,
and the wind, and whatnot.
But as these races and
interest in this world
continue to grow,
suddenly these, you know,
you're sleeping in a tent
at the starting line and
there's two people there,
whatever.
Now there's, you know, media,
and it's money,
and all the commercialization
and all of that,
which obviously is antithetical
to the whole spirit of the entire thing.
But I think what is great about
these self-styled adventures
is that that's where
people's heads are at, right?
I mean, the pandemic,
when all the races ended,
everybody had to get creative
and suddenly you saw
this explosion of people
just saying, well, I don't
need to wait for permission
for this race to happen.
I'm gonna go out and like do my own thing.
And now I feel like
there's a lot of momentum
behind that type of endeavor.
And it doesn't have to be an FKT.
It could just be, hey, I have
a trail a mile from my house
that I've never gone on before.
Let's see what we can do.
Let's have some fun.
- First time is a thing,
but a trail is a thing too.
And just trying to do something
is I think something very good.
And even for me, when I start FKT,
okay, so FKT team must be a good excuse
with all the partner and everything,
and for my feelings,
the best thing is just to try it,
and to do it.
And okay, the race is crowded.
Many people, it's too much sometimes,
but it's, if I did two race,
it's 40 hour and it's 800 hour
of training for 40 hour also.
It's not a lot.
- Right.
(men laughing)
Right.
Fantastic, man.
Well I think that's a good place
to kind of end it for today.
I'm excited to watch you race at Hardrock.
Seems like you're in good spirits
and your body is cooperating,
so I think it's gonna be
exciting to watch that show down.
- Yeah, yeah.
It will be so nice anyway what's happened.
We will see.
And no matter I'm just happy to be there,
and to come back there,
and for me it was a good
moment to share with you
at least then I'm so happy
to make this experience,
and I'm sure I would have some memories
from the next adventure.
- Yeah.
Very cool.
Well, let's continue this
conversation at a later date.
I'd love to have you back on,
and I really appreciate you
bringing all your thoughtfulness
and experience to this conversation.
It's really cool.
So what you're doing is really inspiring.
I think it really inspires all of us
to kind of reach a little
bit further and deeper,
and, you know, kind of what you said
about how it took you 20
years to get where you're at.
It's very easy to look at
someone like yourself and say,
well, it's easy for him.
He's built for this and all of that.
And maybe there's some truth in that.
But you know,
to understand like the passion
that you have for the sport,
the dedication,
and just the love of the outdoors,
and the joyful expression
that you bring to everything that you do,
I think is uplifting
for everybody to hear.
So thank you for that.
- Thank you very much.
- Cool.
All right.
If people wanna learn more about you,
where do you like to direct people?
I mean, your Instagram account,
is that the best place?
- Yeah, I try to be myself
on my social media account.
Yes, of course.
And yeah, I can meet each other
on a trail one day I hope.
But yes, I try to work
a bit on my social media
to share my passion, and my values,
and I hope to inspire to you.
- Cool.
And I'll have links up to all
that stuff in the show notes,
so just check that out,
and thanks, Francois.
- [Francois] Thank you.
- To be continued.
Cheers.
Peace.